alalala pigalle ou
il fait chaud à kigali très chaud même
au coeur de multivers ce quartier c'est
le pari sensuelle le pari érotique le
pari sulfureux depuis plus d'un siècle
villa lui se veut un carrefour à
l'origine de l'ambiance plus galloise
une institution historique a tout
déclenché c'est le moulin rouge des
gants brad et des paillettes depuis 1889
cette empreinte de glamour et de volupté
imprègne tout le quartier
les hommes descendus sous les néons se
laisse happer par tel ou tel cabaret en
69 année érotique un certain jacques
martin nous embarque dans ce pari
sensuelle pourquoi pigalle est là parce
que durant juin et juillet il ya
davantage de célibataire dans paris
j'irai même juin/juillet même août parce
que les femmes sont très souvent partie
avec les enfants à plogastel sur mer ou
à bénodet wasquehal ou à saint tropez et
nous les hommes on s'ennuie à paris et
il y a de quoi faire africaine dans les
années 70 c'est le temple du strip tease
la pratique hérite de l'effeuillage
façon moulin rouge ou un spectaculaire
mais plus aguicheurs pigalle c'est aussi
le charme tarif est celui qui ne se
montre pas à la télé mais évidemment
quand on vous dit pigalle ont convoyé
pigalle ou pensez quoi
dans les années 80 c'est l'âge d'or du
cinéma porno et pigalle est un haut lieu
du genre vous souvenez des films que
vous avez vu que l'esthétique oui la
grande partouze
c'était bien donc j'ai vu trois dans ma
vie ces batailles de l'art du vrai
pigalle en expose en 1997 le musée de
l'érotisme ouvre ses bras aux passants
c'est drôle c'est plein d'humour et
c'est parfois très beau
du coup paris
c'est bien mais c'est fini en 2016 le
musée a fermé ses portes comme les
cinémas pornos avant lui comme la
majorité des clubs de cabaret dans les
années 2000 seuls les sex shops font de
la résistance
reste aussi quelques bars à hôtesses ces
établissements dans lesquels des dames
proposent leur compagnie simple
compagnie officiellement c'est la même
chose pour ma fille les ans glorieux
d'autres moins reluisant les charmes de
pigalle lui ont valu une réputation
sulfureuse et mondial sa renommée
persiste même si elle a perdu de son
sex-appeal îlots de résistance
le moulin rouge lui trône toujours
depuis plus d'un siècle
[Musique]